hey youtubers is Charlie huge news you
guys may have seen all the craziness
about Deadpool maybe being in the
Wolverine movie the actors came out so
I'm gonna explain what's going on and
why everyone's freaking out
in honor of Stan Lee's birthday there's
a new round of the spider-man giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts so you don't miss anything
so what's going on people are saying
that Deadpool is going to be in the
movie the actors came out and said no
that's not the case prisoner 2 for 601
is going to be on a solo mission this is
Bryan Reynolds poking fun at the fact
that Hugh Jackman was in lame is but
then James Mangold the director came out
and was like you know thank you for
responding to this and then Hugh Jackman
just stacked on top of that and was like
yeah what these guys said so what is
happening is it was reported the
Deadpool had shot a scene with the new
Deadpool - director for the new Logan
movie that's being released in March
like the Logan movie is now in
post-production like they're just
finishing some special effects it's
supposed to be like the smaller more
self-contained movie just sort of a
bookend to Hugh Jackman's time as
Wolverine in the Wolverine character
that he originated so that Foxx going
forward can do whatever they want to
with the character when maybe he doesn't
play anymore they as well as Hugh
Jackman had been saying for a while now
that this is going to be his last time
to put the claws on so just don't
believe anything till you actually see
it but for now it seems like it's going
to be his last Wolverine movie but the
rumors just saying that even though
Deadpool 2 isn't going to be shooting
for a while they just you know it's sort
of like a test for the new director and
just to do something fun for the fans
they're putting some Deadpool as a bit
of a tag at the end of the movie and
it's not really going to have a lot to
do with the plot of Logan like okay I'm
gonna play this clip here there was a
clip of Deadpool that they released in
Japan after x-men apocalypse came out
just to make fun of that movie more so
than Deadpool did in the actual Deadpool
movie so here you go oh hi Japan
Deadpool here surprised I just wanted to
share with you my two cents on five
things you
may have missed in the x-men apocalypse
trailer I know what you're thinking an
after credit scene for a trailer I
thought they only did that for movies
right well not everyone makes to the end
of Fox movies so now we're doing it
after trailers number one this movie is
set in the 80s and apparently apocalypse
kicks professor X's ass for forgetting
to wake him up before he go go number
two major plot twist when Quicksilver
discloses to mystique that magneto is
his father and he's a fan of Canadian
supergroup Rush so many plot twists
number three fun fact
sigh lock is a hot looking girl using a
super powered katana and I'm a horrible
looking man using a katana twinsies
number four looks like they're
introducing a Japanese mutant with Ginsu
knives coming out of his hands let's see
how that goes number five this wasn't
really in the trailer but important for
you to know the newest addition to the
super dysfunctional x-men family me
Deadpool comes out in Japan on June 1st
I've definitely never felt power like
this before so be there June first so
you can see how they basically just took
like the x-men apocalypse trailer and
then you shot like a little extra
Deadpool scene and then just jammed it
on the end of the trailer so you have to
imagine that that's what was reported
about this Deadpool cameo in the
Wolverine movie but then fans came out
and were like oh my god it's gonna be a
team-up it's gonna be so amazing say
it's true and then Ryan Reynolds
responded with something like this and
said you know sadly prisoner 2 for 601
is on a solo mission so what Ryan
Reynolds is saying is is that he is not
going to be teaming up with Wolverine in
the Logan movie he's not saying anything
about an end credits scene or any kind
of end tag with Deadpool like there's no
confirmation or denial about any of that
going on in the director james mangold
the reason why he was like oh my god
thank you so much for doing this is
because he doesn't want fans to go see
the new Wolverine movie expecting to see
a Deadpool team-up and then be really
disappointed and really pissed off when
they don't see that so
they're just clarifying that this is a
Logan movie but there will probably be a
funny Deadpool scene for the fans at the
end that will have nothing to do with
the Logan movie it'll just be like
something that they jammed on at the end
where he may be he makes fun of Hugh
Jackman or just pokes fun at the x-men
franchise in general so they're still
locking down their cable actor there's
like a number of different things they
could do with that post-credit scene but
because I'm not expecting it to be super
long it might just be something like the
Ferris Bueller post-credit scene during
the first Deadpool movie you're still
here it's over go home oh you're
expecting a teaser for Deadpool - well
we don't have that kind of money
expecting Sam Jackson show up with it i
patch and a saucy little leather number
go so let me know in the comments what
do you think about all this like what
kind of Deadpool scene did they tack on
to the end of Logan like who is he
making fun of is he just making fun of
Hugh Jackman is he gonna be poking fun
at all the x-men is he gonna be teasing
stuff for the Deadpool sequel like he
did in that Ferris Bueller scene like
you laughed but they hadn't confirmed
cable or anything like that it just that
like Rob Liefeld said that when they
were originally talking about the first
Deadpool movie he was like definitely do
not put cable in the first movie save
him for the next movie so they probably
knew they'd get to cable eventually but
you know nobody knows how well the
movies gonna do till it actually comes
out so they were kind of just having a
little bit of fun with that scene
although it did turn out to be prophetic
like the movie blew up became the
biggest rated R movie of all time so of
course they're gonna do a sequel of
course they're gonna put cable in it but
what about you jack man like if he's not
going to be in the x-men movies anymore
are they still gonna do scenes like this
so here I'm gonna play this clip where
Hugh Jackman was doing some other movie
Ryan Reynolds helped promoted just
because they're good friends they ended
up trolling each other's characters
Wolverine Origins that version of
Deadpool as well as Green Lantern a
little bit so just watch this can many
actors enjoy
forming their own stunts yes do you do
all your own acting if there's sex
scenes I do them yes that's where the
craft is yeah it's a key to a good
marriage did you guys get any notes from
the studio - so Eddie's mouth shut make
lasers shoot from his eyes you know I
didn't but I thought it'd be a great
idea as a story it totally makes sense
part of a set always hunter do you ever
H not since 2009 you're gorgeous so what
I think going forward you know unless
you Jackman just changes his mind and
wants to come back and do more Wolverine
cameos is they'll continue to do stuff
like this because Hugh Jackman is still
gonna keep making movies with Fox
Studios so that means that you'll
probably see more stuff like this you
know where he just like pokes fun at
Ryan Reynolds because now he's the big
man on campus
whereas you know once upon a time
Wolverine was the biggest character at
Fox like before the days of Deadpool
Wolverine was like the one guy that you
could count on you put him in a movie
people will go see that movie now that's
kind of like the Deadpool thing like you
put Deadpool in a movie and it's like
holy [ __ ] we got to go see this so none
of this has anything about what the
future of the main x-men franchise is
going to be they're still kind of
reworking that behind the scenes ramping
up for a Dark Phoenix arc but it sounds
like they're going to be reimagining
rebooting certain elements of the
continuity iron out all the wrinkles so
that going forward they make fans that
both critics and fans are really excited
about because it sounds like a lot of
the fans really enjoy all these movies
but it just does not help when critics
savage your movie no matter which studio
you're at you know whether it's DC
whether it's Marvel whether it's Fox
like everybody making these movies wants
to make a good movie so don't be
surprised if they delay the next x-men
movie for like another year just to give
them extra time to work out a script now
I'm not talking about Deadpool that's
still humming along like everybody's
totally happy with that right now for
those of you asking about a new Logan
trailer new Deadpool footage I'm not
expecting anything until at least the
Superbowl they might drop a little bit
of stuff before then though so just
because they're going to be using a lot
of Deadpool to promote the Logan movie
you know in a roundabout way like I said
with Hugh Jackman and Ryan Reynolds just
having fun with each other they'll
probably start doing that during January
ramping up to another like big Logan
trail
during the Super Bowl so get hype about
that I think it's going to be a really
awesome movie I'm really excited about
the Logan movie
so we'll start hearing a whole lot about
the Deadpool sequel really soon like
they probably already found their cable
and just haven't chose to announce him
yet but as we all continue to say happy
birthday to Stanley it's really gonna be
his birthday for like the rest of the
week when you're 94 you get like an
entire week to celebrate your birthday
so just try to imagine what his cameo is
going to be in the next movie they were
hyping it up on his actual birthday
yesterday like Stanley best cameo ever
is like he's in the strip club
announcing the chastity character so I
will say congratulations to this week's
spot I'm an giveaway winner Richard
Parker you win a $20 Amazon gift card be
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there's a new round now
announce the winner the next time I post
a Marvel video so what's going to happen
next is is there's a couple big things
that just drop there's some new flash
season 3 there's some Game of Thrones
that I want to post there's Superman vs.
Deathstroke so there's all kinds of
Civil War stuff going on too so I'll try
to get that stuff out as fast as
possible whole bunch of comic book stuff
happening to ring in the New Year make
you feel a little bit better about life
in general
while you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for a new spider-man
homecoming footage and you can click
here to learn all about spider-man
upgrades during Avengers infinity war
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you